- Well, Suki and Riley, is it true
that you both went to band camp?
- Oh, we sure did.
- It's definitely true.
Yes. (laughs)
(Riley laughs)
- So what, what was,
what was Band Camp like?
- It was love.
- You sounded like you enjoyed it.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
We did. We really enjoyed it.
But it was, you know,
we worked really hard.
- Yeah.
- A lot of us had never done
the things we were doing on this show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I had never sang,
I'd never played guitar.
Suki hadn't played, you
hadn't played the keys.
You know, the other band
members had either never
played their instruments
or they hadn't in a while.
- Mm.
- We spent a lot of time
in that room together.
- Do you do it now?
Like obviously you do, but like
do you play now outside of it?
'Cause now, I don't know.
I imagine when you learn something
as an actor, like I,
I, anything you learn,
I've talked to someone that learned how
they had to learn how to swim
to like, for their role or whatever.
I'm like, do you keep that up?
- So I, I definitely like, feel
more confident singing now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I'll, like
if my husband sings for
example, I'll sing with him.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- More than I would have before.
The songs I know are
just Daisy Jones songs.
- Yeah. (laughs)
So I am amazing at those.
- I'm good at those
so like, I can play those.
- She's being humble.
- She's got like one of the better voices
I've ever heard in my-
- A stunning voice.
- She belts in this show. She's really-
- Okay, you're also-
- You're really great.
- by the way-
- And you have a-
- No, no.
- great voice as well.
- By the way. She's got a
beautiful voice as well.
- You guys, we're with like Kelly Clarkson
so we cannot talk about singing.
- No, I love it.
I love - this is where you talk about it.
I'm a singer. I love it.
- And Camila does.
- Well obviously we
know Suki is a rockstar,
but in this show, Riley has got,
I mean her voice, it's very,
it really does remind me of
like Stevie Nicks and
it has a Janice Joplin-
- [Kelly] Oh my God. That's cool.
- Joni Mitchell vibe.
- I mean,
- That is way overselling it.
- I think.